-Performing "When You're Gone,"
once again, my cohost, my hero,
Shawn Mendes!
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ You never know
how good you have it ♪
♪♪
♪ Until you're staring
at a picture ♪
♪ Of the only girl
that matters ♪
♪♪
♪ I know what ♪
♪ We're supposed to do ♪
♪ It's hard for me ♪
♪ To let go of you ♪
♪ So I'm just trying
to hold on, hold on ♪
♪ I don't wanna know what
it's like when you're gone ♪
♪ I don't wanna move on ♪
♪ I don't wanna know
what it's like ♪
♪ When you're gone for good ♪
♪ You're slipping
through my fingertips ♪
♪ A little bit ♪
♪ By a little bit ♪
♪ I didn't know
that loving you ♪
♪ Was the happiest ♪
♪ I've ever been ♪
♪ So I'm just trying
to hold on ♪
♪♪
♪ I need to learn how
to cope without you ♪
♪♪
♪ I'm trying to protect myself,
but only you know how to ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ Oh, I know what ♪
♪ We're supposed to do ♪
♪ I hate the thought ♪
♪ Of losing you ♪
♪ So I'm just trying
to hold on, hold on ♪
♪ I don't wanna know what
it's like when you're gone ♪
♪ I don't wanna move on ♪
♪ I don't wanna know
what it's like ♪
♪ When you're gone for good ♪
♪ You're slipping
through my fingertips ♪
♪ A little bit ♪
♪ By a little bit ♪
♪ I didn't know
that loving you ♪
♪ Was the happiest ♪
♪ I've ever been ♪
♪ So I'm just trying
to hold on ♪
♪ Starting to feel
like you don't need me ♪
♪ Wanna believe it's
all for the better ♪
♪ It's getting real,
I'm missing you deeply, yeah ♪
♪ So I'm just trying
to hold on ♪
♪ Starting to feel
like you don't need me ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
-♪ Wanna believe ♪
-♪ It's all for the better ♪
♪ Oh, no ♪
♪ I'm missing you deeply, yeah ♪
♪♪
♪ Hold on ♪
♪ I don't wanna know what
it's like when you're gone ♪
♪ I don't wanna move on ♪
♪ I don't wanna know
what it's like ♪
♪ When you're gone for good ♪
♪ You're slipping through my ♪
-♪ Fingertips ♪
-♪ A little bit ♪
♪ By a little bit ♪
♪ I didn't know
that loving you ♪
♪ Was the happiest, oh ♪
♪ I've ever been ♪
♪ So I'm just trying
to hold on ♪
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]